hi I'm ray these are some of my favorite
Japanese noodles
[Music]
Yacouba it's kind of like mac and cheese
for me it's easy to make you can make a
lot of it and my mom used to make x over
all the time for my lunch
[Music]
so the first recipe is classic yakisoba
tasty Japan's making four different
buttons here basically excavates usually
needle cabbage kara bean sprout thinly
sliced pork tossed with the yakisoba
sauce which is sweet savory and tangy
all at the same time it's very similar
to economy axles but slightly thinner
it's kind of like Japanese Charmin you
may only be familiar with the basic
style but there are a bunch of different
way of making it the second is salt and
lemon I started seeing a lot of trend
where salt lemon combination it's
getting very popular in Japan this is
lighter than the sauce one also yakisoba
you often will find on the street it's
very much a Japanese Street food you can
also find in Japan on instant version so
you can just pour hot water drain the
water and add a sauce it's kind of like
mulch and ramen but we have this
reaction of ajanta the options are
unlimited the third one is the Takumi
Chi with all its pork and kimchi pork
and kimchi flavor combination is very
popular as well if you go to okonomiyaki
place you will see this flavor
combination very often it's a Japanese
take on more of Korean style dish I feel
like it's more Japanese people have
started using kimchi in our daily food
so I think it's kind of a future
you can order your favorite vegetables
and protein and make it a little
healthier and make it fancy the first
one is a little bit fancy it's more
seafood
he had shrimp and squid it also has a
little quail egg well egg it's super
easy to find every grocery store has it
pretty much you may only be familiar
with the basic style but there are a
bunch of different ways to make yakisoba
that you should strike it's easy and
simple with proteins and vegetables
nutritious and delicious dish there are
a lot of different way of making it if
you have any other creative ideas let me
know go make it and go make it fancy
[Music]
this is a recipe for cold udon it uses
eggplant and tomatoes so it's more for
like summer
I love it fun and it's so good so in the
summertime in Japan it's very humid and
it's super hot so this is the perfect
dish for the kind of summer
[Music]
[Applause]
that ballsy uses it's meant to you meant
to you eat soy sauce paste with dashi
and it's a kind of dipping sauce you can
use it for a lot of dishes like salmon
and dipping sauce or tempura man means
noodle and to you it's dipping sauce
this concentrated pre-made sauce is used
mainly for like various different kind
of noodle dishes
[Music]
[Applause]
you can make it from scratch but it's
very easy to find in a grocery store and
I think you can find it in an Asian
grocery story in the US if you want to
make it from scratch you can make it
with dashi and soy sauce and meaning but
if you use meant to you you can make
good on the win
[Music]
the last time I made Rudolfo a video it
was beef udon and a kitsune udon but
this one is different because it's for
summer build on so this is different
because it's not served hot and uses
different ingredients like summer
vegetable
[Music]
like yakisoba you can experiment with it
maybe you can make Italian Oh Dom I've
seen carbonara you don't before we're
always like a blank canvas so experiment
with that and experiment with your
favorite flavors and ingredients and
make your own food on ramen is very
popular fast food in Japan and I think
it's getting more popular in the States
as well everyone loves ramen right I
feel like in here the popular bras it's
usually tonkotsu ramen and Hong Kong so
it's made with pork so it's a little
heavy to me so whenever I go back to
Japan I always see my favorite style
which is show you which is soy sauce
paste or salt which eats chicken broth
paste because it's a little lighter than
tonkatsu I also love soft-boiled egg in
ramen and it's very easy to make
you just boil water and put the egg in
it and wait for 6 to 7 minutes this
ramen recipe is developed by Daiki in
tasty Japan and I'm so glad that he made
this video so I can make a home and
another popular flavor it's miso ramen
mr. ami is miso-based broth it's very
good sometimes it can wait miss on
butter and sometimes it's a little spicy
my favorite toppings for ramen is Menma
which is bamboo shoot' kind of has a
little crunchy texture to it so it gives
a nice texture into ramen because rama
it's usually soft it's constable like
slow fast food because it takes a long
time to make it but it's very fast to
serve you can find ramen shop easily in
LA but if you want to make a home that
is ramen noodles you can find any Asian
grocery stores it usually comes with
brass too
[Music]
so this recipe is very easy to make a
home so please give it a try
[Music]